[Music]
all right as if i we needed any more
motivation to get out and vote in the
midterms get this
dianne feinstein she wants to now open
up
an eighth investigation reopen a sexual
assault investigation into brett
kavanaugh
if the democrats retake the senate you
got to be kidding me here with reaction
to all this
south carolina senator lindsey graham
senator good to see you
thank you another investigation
there was no corroboration in the first
one none well
it's not funny but in a way it is i mean
apparently one kick of a mule is not
enough for
senator feinstein who i like very much
but here's what i want
every democratic candidate for the
senate to be asked tomorrow
do you agree with dianne feinstein if
democrats take control of the senate
are you for reopening the kavanagh
investigation
are you far more humiliation degrading
treatment of this fine man
are you for continuing this debacle do
you agree with dianne feinstein if you
get in charge of the senate's democrats
you're going to go after kavanaugh again
i think every voter and all these trump
states
that have democratic senators needs to
ask that question
are you with diane or not we've been
talking a lot about
hillary's comments kick americolder you
know we have two we have now
two politicians republicans in minnesota
have been
assaulted and punched one guy severely
injured a woman punched
maxine waters create a crowd you know
follow them into grocery stores gas
stations
department stores they're not wanted
anywhere anymore like
she wants she's going to be a leader if
they take back the house
well i think this is what happens by the
way
yeah i'll tell you about that this is
what happens when you can't win at the
ballot box
you take those of us who did win and you
try to intimidate us
into bending to your will i've never had
police
security before capitol police protect
me ever before until
the kavanaugh hearings i had a guy would
not let the elevator close
i had to go you know go to my office and
somebody on the elevator pushed him out
i don't know what i would have done
had a bunch of people around me filming
me yelling at me saliva
all over my jacket it was pretty bad and
i can only imagine what my other
colleagues
went through so this is on the ballot
what do you want america to look like
once the election's over
do you want those who lost to try to
physically assault
those who won or do you want to have an
election once it's over we try to work
together and govern the country
isn't that what it should be about at
the end of the day
i'm willing to listen to any democrat
tell me what you're going to do
to create jobs you know remember 10
years working in restaurants starting as
a dishwasher
10 years in construction starting as a
house painter and
you know roofing falling three stories
that's my background you grew up in a
bar
and and you had the same kind of
background i just
we now have four million new jobs 400
000 manufacturing jobs
better trade deals less regulation a
path to energy independence the biggest
tax cut in history
we're securing the border north korea um
you know i'm thinking wow this is a
there's a lot at stake here yeah you
know
israel's safer isis is being destroyed
you know
president trump asked the question in
2016 what do you have to lose and most
people said not much
they saw no hope of hillary clinton let
me tell you in 2018
if democrats take over you got a lot to
lose
and i want every democrat who's running
for the senate to answer the question
do you agree with dianne feinstein that
we should reopen the kavanaugh
investigation
if democrats take over they want to
impeach
the guy house members need to be asked
that if you're running for the house as
a democrat do you agree with the idea
that the first thing you should do is
impeach kavanaugh these answers tell you
a lot about the person running
so they need to are you with diane or
not are you with the american people the
american people are pleased
that we got a good conservative justice
they're ready to move on
there was only one democrat that was
willing to let
due process the presumption of innocence
ruled the death
only one and not one other and joe
listened to west virginia
and i want to see who these other
democrats are listening to clearly they
didn't listen to the people of their
states
but if i am in charge as a republican
senator grassley did a wonderful job but
i may be the chairman
if he moves to finance i promise you
this we're going to investigate who
betrayed dr ford
i'm going to find out why her lawyers
did not tell her
that the committee would have gone to
california to interview her
in private so she didn't have to go
through this
that's what i'm going to investigate
senator i think you had one of your
finance monuments in your career
standing up for truth
standing up for honesty and fundamental
core
american values and uh we appreciate
that you did that thank you
thank you